and he repeatedly said that I threatened
to kill his children you know what
because I've seen no consequences at all
and no consequences just for being an
overall crappy teacher I'm gonna just
say the guy threatened to kill my kids
guess to be that extreme because there
are no consequences as a matter of fact
it's encouraged
we come to you with an update today on
none other than Charles Hermes professor
at UTA we have some documents here and I
do want to hear from you I guess the
question of the day is I know everyone
was saying cilium sue the school or I
said Hannes and let's let cooler heads
prevail let it sit a little bit and of
course we haven't sued anybody what we
have done is what's the exact the legal
term here my half-asian lawyer Phil
Richmond everybody we filed an open
records request and open records request
so for people who don't know explain
what that is before we get to these
hilarious
documents at the federal level at the
state level most states have some kind
of requests that you can go to a state
body an organization University and
agency and say hey I want to see what
your records are some exceptions there
but you generally can get what you're
asking for for those who don't remember
this is of course the Crowder confronts
professor who accused me of being a
neo-nazi and posted false I think was
false memes of me saying gasps the Jews
and also French yeah really yeah I mean
what mean-spirited and also
mean-spirited to falsely attribute those
quotes to myself they tried to say that
they were just gonna wait til everything
get decided but I pushed them and they
produced a first set of documents that
are not being scrutinized by the Texas
Attorney General and that's what we have
today so in other words it would be
reasonable to infer that these are the
least damning of the documents so
whatever's coming down the pike is
probably substantially worse if they
didn't want us to see it yeah you would
think the one that they're still trying
to keep from us are going to be worse
and there are quite a few things here so
if we take you to the first document
there's a long history of emotional
instability so before we get to the bias
before we get to the mistreatment at
what I would see is mistreatment of
students are having different political
worldviews there's just a general
consistency there's a consistent threat
of him being emotionally unstable this
comes from summer 2017 I'm just gonna
read the highlights here you guys can
all read along talking about Professor
Hermes he got emotional and almost
started crying we expect the instructors
to be professional and act
a certain way I would say almost 80% of
the course time he was emotional felt
like he would cry and then everyone
around him starts feeling bad gets
depressed it's very much important for
him to get some kind of counseling and
therapy another one to I'm kind of
jumping around chronologically this was
from me first where Charles Hermes again
was saying last year I started my first
class knowing something was seriously
wrong then he goes on and say something
was seriously wrong I could not focus to
complete even the simplest of tasks I
started talking about how labor in
America has treated how racial issues
are treated how I could not sit by
anymore and pretend it wasn't happening
at the end of the talk I raise my fist
if this is Charles Hermes talking raised
my fist to the air and gave the loudest
scream I ever gave in my life dot dot
dot strike he said I said strike to my
students then I left campus for the day
way to put in your hours then a few
hours later my boss called asking where
I was I told him it was International
labor day and I was on strike for a
moment I thought I might have lost my
job I'll admit the day was a moment of
insanity it's where I snapped throughout
the last year I've clung to that moment
of insanity you don't cling to a moment
of insanity no you tend to run towards
Sam you tend to cling to your one moment
of sanity if you're an insane person
when this would seem like the
limitations of an insane person he says
I can think of no more fitting
description for May 1st 2017 and to say
that was the day I was reborn into a
crazy person so he says I was reborn I'm
crazy and then you go back in time and
there were students saying hey this guy
seems on he seems unstable he seems
crazy
these are his public statements I mean
these are yeah some of this is this is a
statement this is not public I think
this one's right right right the first
one was from a student right and then he
publicly confirmed it by saying I mean
it was my moment of insanity and it's
what kept me from becoming sane here we
have a complaint this is a constant
threat to this is a direct violation of
the university's mission to promote free
expression in an atmosphere of tolerance
responsibility and Trust he often uses
the word fascism but as actions our
textbook definition of fascism again
this is before the crowd of confronts
absolutely so these are and by we've had
a lot of emails from people I think we
have an email up at do we have an email
at ladder with credit calm right now
you're gonna send it to tips a lot of
credit calm but we will have emails
specifically for professors we want your
footage we want your feedback we want
your professor reviews so that we can
help kids out there because there's been
a lot of students apparently suffering
in silence and that's what's important
to note like he didn't get our show
banned but not everyone has this
platform and my heart really breaks for
kids going hey I think this professor is
a little unstable you know what this
might be this could be a kid saying hey
this professor is failing me because I
disagree with him and he definitely
seems like he's on stick can you guys
look into it
something else you were mentioning - it
doesn't seem from from all of these and
we'll get through a few more there's
been no there been no reprimands from
what we've seen in the records they
produce so far nothing corroborates that
they did anything to address his public
Testament that he's going to remain
willfully insane in addition to all of
the complaints from the students and
that's separate and apart from when he
started accusing you of false statements
right as a matter of fact we have one
could almost say that the end of this
show they rewarded him not only was it
not reprimanded you'll get to see as we
go along down the illaha cold trail how
bad it is
read this can you read this one for me
here documents that I do I do I
sometimes get emails from him prior to
class while advising him I just don't
correct the errors and had not oh I'd
sometimes get emails from him prior to
class while advising other students that
had not yet seen it until we talked
about the content in class while I was
in a meeting with a student and after
that meeting I had my exam and after the
exam I meet the teachers night at school
Wednesday early day I had doctors
appointments followed by finishing
back-to-school work for blank and then
was working on email late afternoon what
the hell does that mean
first off who wrote it well you would
think my full Asian mom wrote it but so
this is we have more by the way after
Crowder confronts video and this is
something else that I want to talk about
the reason that we don't typically go
the legal route is because hey you and I
both know there are bigger legal battles
to fight as it relates to big tech we
know there's I mean you've heard a lot
of other people complain and kind of
leave patreon we've created mug clubs
specifically to avoid that battle right
so we don't have a fight with patreon we
don't want to get into legal battles we
want to create content bill knows that
Bill has probably done more work in
creating content for the show and
educating you on legal issues than
actually fighting legal battles for us
that being said we try to keep our
powder dry so we don't sue every Tom
Dick and Harry but a lot of people have
been calling for some kind of action to
be taken here because there are a lot of
students out there who feel really
helpless
here's one after the video this person
said after seeing away after seeing the
way a member of your hired faculty
Charles Hermes has behaved in
participating in libel against someone i
rescind my interest in your university
this person by the way has a master's
and was looking at getting another
postgraduate degree yeah and said I'm
just I'm not going to do it at UT
Arlington yeah this person again in
relation to Charles Hermes when I read
there is also a component of
intimidation and mislabelling of some
students he disagrees with to be
abhorrent and unacceptable oh sorry I
read the second half of the phrase this
phrase actually is not a run-on sentence
I read half of it my apologies this
person wrote it if this is true I hope
these students will capture this bias on
video recording and post it to social
media so here's something to when they
say we don't want to record this because
that's for the safety of our students
that's what went in for the safety of
our students on a second we've received
messages from some students right who
would go to that school and I said
please we want more recording no no it's
only to protect the people who want to
operate in the dark there are a lot of
students who want transparency yeah
namely the students who are being failed
the students who are being discriminated
against because of their views by
professor this idea that all students
feel unsafe if somehow this conversation
is being recorded it's not true some of
these and that this is someone the same
person this seems to be there seemed to
be more students and professors that are
on our campuses for the wrong reasons
some of these institutions are seeing
lower enrollment rates due to concerns
of parents this person is not I don't
believe this person as a student we have
had to redact the the information there
I think it's actually someone who works
if I'm not mistaken we don't have all of
it so don't I'm not lying if I misspeak
here I believe this is someone who might
work in some sector of Education here
saying we're noticeably seeing a
decrease in enrollment because of this
there's no evidence here that anything
has been done to re guide but this is
ample evidence that he lied and that's
the product confronts with with me and
my girlfriend oh and Benjamin's gonna be
in the show on Thursday by the way and
in the big people why do you dress up in
the silly outfits it's to draw attention
to this and if you remember was a big
arrow that said not a Nazi because this
guy lied and said that I was a Nazi and
when we went and confronted him in front
of the class and said but those you know
that these means that these pictures
that these statements are a lie he said
no and he repeatedly said that I
threatened to kill his children by the
way if I ever threatened the lives of
his children seems like that would be in
these documents right one would think
yeah you think so if it's something
where you're not going hey can we seal
these we're gonna hear Mangia Mangia
take this stuff seems like anything that
I had sent that would be a threat would
be here yeah when they're making the
specific claim he threatened the lives
of my children right he threatened to
gas the Jews that's where my antennae go
up and I go hold on a second yeah this
is getting pretty specific specific and
the reason someone feels confident doing
that is because they've gone unchecked
with the transphobia comment with the
racism comments with the bigotry
comments with the prejudice comments
with the sexism comments to racism
comments so that goes unchecked because
you can't really check it right now it's
it's it's like a hypothesis you can
never really test it and they've got the
backing of the Union but that yeah but
then that person says oh you know what
because I've seen no consequences at all
and no consequences just for being an
overall crappy teacher I'm gonna just
say the guy threatened to kill my kids
you gonna how does it get to be that
extreme it gets to be that extreme
because there are no consequences as a
matter of fact it's encouraged how do I
know it's encouraged let me bring you to
this final little tonight now by the way
we're gonna keep you posted and again
let me know if you think there should be
some kind of legal action here what you
think the next step should be do you
think that this information is enough
that this has been helpful enough and it
by the way if you're a student
we want to hear from you we want to see
you rating your professors yeah
transparencies the name of the game this
was September 20th two days after the
Crowder confronts video seriously guess
who won
runner-up for UT a faculty advisor of
the year
Charles Hermes Bravo
why does someone like this feel
emboldened not only because you don't
punish him not only because you don't
correct even inaccuracies but when he
blatantly lies and abuses students non
students through his words to
intimidation you give him oh not the
award runner up this man is a lecturer
of logic I think is it logic and debate
logic logic and something else that was
equally a Roger so what do we what do we
expect next what we're looking to get
another set of documents once the Texas
Attorney General is done doing its
reviews how many documents that is what
will be in there we don't know again our
best guess would be that if there's a
set of documents that they are actively
trying to keep withheld those probably
have worse information than we already
have but we'll have to wait to see that
the Texas Attorney General's Office this
division gets inundated with these
requests they cover the entire state so
it is a process but as soon as we get
the rest of those everyone will be the
first to know but for people out there
who wonder you know obviously laterthe
Grindr comm slash mug club for people a
lot of you are watching on mug Club some
of you might be watching this on youtube
or something you might have illegally
downloaded this we just ask that you
don't we don't really do a whole lot
with that what's the new what's the one
kids use now it says it LimeWire like
still running the file-sharing program I
think but that's why we have local
that's what we're able to have
half-asian lawyer builders maintainer
our standard is we want to focus on
content a lot of people make their
content nothing but legal battles like
I'm suing this person look I'm this is
censorship join me and support me on
patreon the truth is the bulk of our
content is simply content for
entertainment and our standard is if
there is something that will impede our
ability to create content on a long-term
basis you know for example we get
copyright claims because we're doing a
parody and we say well you know what
this videos demonetized but it's not
necessarily worth our fight but if
something is actually going to impede us
from creating content those are the
battles that we pick i don't know that
charles Hermes prevents us from creating
content in future I know we've been
banned from some schools in the past
based on lies but I do know that it
harms a lot of viewers out there and a
lot of students and of not even students
a lot of people let's say who are in
business who are being censored because
I don't on this platform and that's how
we pick our battles that's why it's so
important to hear from you because we
want to know which battles you think are
worth it because we don't want to fight
battles that take us away from content
is there anything else here that I
missed stay tuned stay tuned as we get
more of these documents and we do want
to hear from you what you think we
should be doing here with Professor
Charles Hermes and of course this year I
believe we're going to be doing one show
at a school this semester our new rule
going forward is we're going to do the
Halloween spooktacular as a live show
and possibly a st. Patrick's Day
extravaganza on campus because it's you
know bringing our show out you've come
out it's so much work it's I would love
to do Notre Dame but I don't know if
they would let us do it they can make
that out it's a lot of work it requires
bringing out not only our whole crew but
getting day Raiders getting the
equipment in getting set up several days
before but that is something that we're
looking to do so of course obviously the
culture on college campus is important
to us and it's not only important to us
to do our shows but it's really
important to me to see that people who
watch the show a lot of your college
students that you're able to speak
freely that you're able to not live in
fear no one should live in fear whether
it's a trans person wanting to take a
dump in the other bathroom listen it
doesn't mean that they have the right to
drop a deuce anywhere they want but that
person shouldn't live in fear of being
attacked just as if you're a
conservative you shouldn't live in fear
of being failed or being kicked out of a
campus simply for holding views that by
the way half the country hold hey here
Here I am drinking from my mug in a
button-down how often do you see this
never so do me a favor and yourself
click one of these videos playing in one
of these boxes here or a subscribe hit a
notification bell also because
subscriptions don't really mean a whole
lot if you really want to support the
show join my club if you don't then
there's no helping you